yeah welcome to this video a bit late
here because I'd some audio issues again
I'm playing some guy with the American
flag here the US flag and carve the 2013
sounds like em presidential campaign
it's not that that far yet okay okay
let's let's take this poor now this some
form of a banker was actually a not
particularly grateful like if I'm able
to maintain a piece on b5 supported by a
4y dumb has an excellent position let's
see what setup is coming up with my turn
to Jesus have meal I can actually go
here if you take so I can take with the
with a night as well
the problem is some with the piece on b5
it's very difficult for black to get any
real play on the B porn or the B file in
general
yep trying to exchange one half nights
the question is should i actually do
that you can also go here and I do so
he's got two nights and I'm threatening
two nights for one square and I'm
threatening f4 now winning a piece so
you probably needs to move one of those
pieces again or play some jams like f5
which really we can serve a lot yeah
maybe needs to do something like this
move like at five yeah well this the
second I cannot play a 55 you can take
on b5 which isn't too bad but also not
not great so how to continue maybe I can
play just be three and you should be too
when the bishop arrives on be too I have
a five so Danny needs to take and v3
it's not a bad move anyway it covers c4
okay I'll take what I fatigued with the
mighty handsome has a check here okay
this is not too too terrible I can just
take with the bishop
now BRB to coming yeah this looks like
just the next report it's not tea and
what kind of compensation black should
have him now f5 the question is should i
play f4 should i take if i take he takes
with the bishop not sure that I want to
want to see that he might play a form
this is some possibility if I go at four
he might play night chief rights it's
not them it's not so clear
alright so I allow him to play a for if
he really wants
always asking me if there will be a
commentary of this game yeah
yeah I just uh oh is it
okay so he's got the f are now maybe
Bishop f5 try to get some counter play
yeah black is still as fairly active
pieces so that some black soap in this
position
a positive thing is I'm actually ahead
on the clock which happens rarely enough
okay so see form form how to proceed
maybe I should play a five attack this
night yeah if he retreats the light I'm
able to take see form so he probably
needs to take on b3 and after Queen B 3
i'm still controlling see form so that
it probably needs to drop it back to d7
and the same should be nice really white
so Bishop c6 will now be late doesn't
doesn't lead to so much
yeah maybe a six John come on just press
play six don't spend too much time i 95
of course oh just night c5 i have i
blundered this this bloody palm ok yeah
95 was a big problem not quite sure how
to how to continue now even this night
c5 is still learn still on
that's no way to cover this
no way to cover the porn
maybe this one might be 5 9 p-5 9p 397
yeah I'll queen retreats and then I p5
okay I can take it which I completely
overlooked before
maybe here I don't know this um I'm very
slow him at some the first game in the
session which always spells trouble it's
some way ok I won't want to get should
be foreign now Bishop a 60s got a very
silly game from both sides actually okay
yeah Bishop basics and watch what do I
move after this I've no no we move you
will take their money he will take e to
ya then now he's got the ton of pieces I
can resign that yeah really terrible
game really terrible game yeah if this
is some this is just they're just
winning for white but I played is
terribly I completely overlooked at
first that that the knight on e4 is
covering c5 so 95 isn't even even a move
but a successor is just is just a bit
too early he gets some me get some
squares and it's still better for white
of course but it's not the best way to
to win this position yeah I completely
forgot that that 95 is not even a move I
mean like a support down it has really
bad position so some it's just a matter
of good technical play Queen 82 is the
computer suggestion yeah the ideas that
Bishop c6 is the threat after that now
Bishop c6 he can answer with rupee aid
and it's not it's not immediately
winning and yeah Queenie achoo is a
strong move can look at this brief lame
game now I'm intending intending this I
black as he cannot move me and it
doesn't have any single meaningful move
when Quincy seven and now you can you
can try to try to improve on that on
that position on that black black has no
move he goes so it goes here I can just
take this and probably something like
that coming jump like it's busted but I
had simply am simply played a terrible
game starting with this and yeah well
this is this is so winning of course but
I just I just overlooked rupee 80 and
this is this is too bad i spent far too
much time because i was so irritated
that I completely this 95 issue yeah
well that game leaves room for big
improvement in the in the next next
games thanks for watching